[Music]
let's pretend that you're
at the park okay you're alone with your
baby you have nothing to defend yourself
except a stroller which is not only a
great weapon but it's also a great probe
to see what your critical distance is so
let's get the stroller out
great and then asian baby
whoa
this is my asian baby asian baby that's
your stroller
okay and uh and here i am with the
stroller why is the baby not in the
stroller because you wouldn't be able to
use it as a self-defense weapon you
don't want to use the baby as a weapon
so you're going to use the stroller's
weapon
so when i'm taking my baby around i will
hold it and push an empty stroller
in for various parts of town yes okay
makes no
so thugs are going to come at you
starting with jackson what who's this
what's he doing who who's coming
what do i do ah all right get it back to
my circle all right
all right wait till he comes wait till
he comes
one more guy's coming right there right
there right there what are you gonna do
roll it through what do i do
great
[Applause]
[Applause]
no no more they're dead
he's a killer okay excellent that was
pretty good okay that was pretty good
pretty good i went
no you look you took everybody's
crawling away okay
so now we're gonna take it up a notch if
you're ready for it up a notch up a
notch the hell was that maybe two
notches okay so we're gonna move over
here this is a designated set for you
this is a replica of my home
that's funny to you
this morning so this will give you an
idea of what you're like in a regular
home situation you're a single father
you're a kid single child i'm drinking
beer alone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like al bundy here all right
so take them take a moment and scan the
area to see what possible weapons you
can use
as weapons for self-defense here i'm
gonna guess this axe will come in
there's always something obvious always
good to have an axe hanging around so
you're just but no when i'm hanging out
with my baby there's usually a beer and
hairspray
all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
what
[Applause]
go go
[Music]
excellent excellent fantastic work
i think i don't think this helped
anybody but it was a lot of fun
all right turtle thanks steven ho he's
the best